هل تحل الصين محل روسيا في اسيا الوسطى
سؤال بات يتردد في الاونه الاخيره خاصه مع
تحركات الصين في تلك المنطقه فرئيس الصيني
التقى بزعماء اسيا الوسطى يوم الخميس
الماضي وكعاده التنين الاسيوي تركزت معظم
المباحثات حول التجاره لكن زعيمه بكين
تحدث ايضا عن مساعده دول اسيا الوسطى على
تحسين انفاذ القانون والامن والقدره
الدفاعيه هذا الخطاب هو جزء لا يتجزا من
تركيز الصين المتزايد على الامن العالمي
والذي يبدو موجها الى حد كبير الى
الولايات المتحده
راقبت الاجتماع عن كثب ومخاوفها تتركز على
ان دول اسيا الوسطى تبحث عن شريك امنيا
موثوقا به في غياب روسيا وفي نفس الوقت لا
تبحث عن شريك ضد روسيا ما يعني ان
الولايات المتحده ليست خيارا فما تريده
الحكومات الاقليميه في اسيا الوسطى كما
تقول فورن بوليسي ليس الحمايه ضد القوه
العظمى بل ضمانا امنيا ضد التمردات
المحليه روسيا كانت لعبت هذا الدور سابقا
وارسلت الاف الجنود الى كازاخستان
للمساعده في اخماد انتفاضه مناهضه للحكومه
لكن تورطها في الحرب الاوكرانيه افصح
المجال امام الصين لتكون البديل لكن هذا
لا يعني ان يتم فصل روسيا عن اسيا الوسطى
او العكس فطالما ان موسكو وبيكين تعتبران
واشنطن عدوا لهما فان التنافس السلمي
نسبيا على النفوذ سيبقى مقبولا
[موسيقى]
ومن التمدد الصيني في اسيا الوسطى الى
التنافس بين بكين و واشنطن للسيطره على
مستقبل افريقيا الاخضر فالقاره السمراء
موطن العديد من المواد الخام في سباق
الحياد الكربوني ففي سعيهما نحو ازاله
مخاطر الكربون تحتاج الولايات المتحده
واوروبا لافريقيا للوصول الى هذه الغايه
لكن عقبه الصين تواجه تلك المساء الغربيه
في افريقيا وتعيقها فبعد عقود من
الدبلوماسيه الصينيه الناجحه ومساعدات
التنميه في هذه القاره يحتاج الغرب الى
اعاده بناء الشراكات هناك وفقا لمبادئ
المعامله بالمثل فمليارات الصين المستثمره
لقد صدى لدى الدول الافريقيه التي غالبا
ماتتهم الغرب بالنفاق فيما يتعلق بمساله
الطاقه وتحول نحو النظيفه منها خاصه بعد
ازمه الغاز الروسي اما بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده فحققت تقدما افضل من اوروبا
التزمت باستثماراتها للحفاظ على الامن
الغذائي والبنيه التحتيه للطاقه المتجدده
في افريقيا يقدر الخبراء ان الصين استثمرت
بالفعل ما مجموعه 120 مليار دولار في
افريقيا بين عامي 2007 و20 في حين استثمرت
الولايات المتحده 20 مليار دولار فقط خلال
نفس الفتره احد ابرز اوجه السباق بين
واشنطن وبكين في افريقيا بالذات هو الوصول
الى المواد الخام الحاسمه في صناعه عده
مثل البطاريات والالواح الشمسيه وتمثل
البلدان الافريقيه بالفعل اكثر من خمس
انتاج الليثيوم وثلثي لانتاج العالمي من
الكوبالت والبوكسايت والبلاتين والعديد من
المواد الاخرى تسيطر الصين على سلسله
توريد باكملها في افريقيا تقريبا من
استخراج والشحن الى التكرير والمعالجه
ويتعين على صناع السياسات في اوروبا
والولايات المتحده ان يبداوا في الاستماع
الى ما يطلبه نظرائهم الافارقه هذا يعني
مزيد من الاستثمارات كما تقول ف اليسي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات